[Music]
hello everyone it's seven o'clock riding
out the wave that was the message from
the prime minister yesterday as he
rejected calls for tougher restrictions
and told the country plan b measures
should be enough to combat the omicron
wave of covert infections but with staff
absences and isolation leading to
several nhs trusts declaring critical
incidents he's expected to face scrutiny
during pmqs in the commons later today
thus could testing rules be said to
change sky news understands that those
testing positive on lateral flows will
be told they don't then need pcrs lots
to talk about were for health minister
jillian keegan and labour's pat mcfadden
today
also this morning how to make a healthy
start to 2022 we're going to talk to two
vegan food bloggers about the huge
growth and veganuri and some recipes you
could try for yourself
also the marathon man hoping to raise a
million for macmillan cancer support
we're going to talk to gary mckee about
his latest challenge to run 365
marathons in 365 days that's at a
quarter tonight
it's wednesday the 5th of january
riding the wave as hospitals and
essential services struggle the prime
minister faces a showdown in the commons
as he resists new covert restrictions
in europe infections explode with france
seeing a record number of cases as
president macron promises
to hassle be unvaccinated
prince andrew awaits a decision on
whether the sexual assault lawsuit he's
facing can go ahead
kazakhstan's government resigns
following widespread protests over
soaring fuel prices
and anger in australia as novak djokovic
has granted a medical exemption to
travel to melbourne to defend his
australian open title with fellow
players questioning the move
i think if it was
me that wasn't vaccinated i wouldn't be
getting an exemption
the weather today will be cold and
largely fine but there'll be a few
wintry showers around mainly over
northern scotland northern ireland and
wales
[Music]
good morning as nps return to
westminster today the prime minister
boris johnson will tell his cabinet that
there's no need for more covert
restrictions despite omicron cases
reaching record levels it comes as
multiple nhs trusts have declared
critical emergencies with 17 major
hospitals in greater manchester pausing
some non-urgent surgery and appointments
because of staff shortages due to covert
while food processing bin collection and
travel services are also being impacted
by staff absences mr johnson says the
nhs is on a wall footing but he's
backing plan b as our chief political
correspondent john craig reports
situation critical up to a dozen nhs
trusts have now declared they're facing
very serious pressure because of staff
absences
in the latest emergency move 17 major
hospitals in greater manchester have
suspended non-urgent surgery and
treatment
but it's not just the nhs that's on the
brink one in 10 railway staff are absent
some supermarkets also report more than
one in 10 staff absent from work and for
some smaller food shops and importers
it's one in five on our retail side
we're running around 15
absentee due to covet
and
on our wholesale side we're running
around 20
bin collections are being delayed too
because of staff shortages leading to
post-christmas waste and recycling
piling up in the streets in some areas
boris johnson says the government will
provide lateral flow tests to a hundred
thousand critical workers every day
starting on monday
today as mps return to westminster after
their christmas break the cabinet meets
to review restrictions introduced before
christmas
but the pm is sticking with plan b
we have a chance
to ride out this omicron wave without
shutting down our country once again as
our nhs moves to a war footing i will be
recommending to cabinet that we continue
with plan b
on the streets of west london there's
relief that there'll be no new curbs in
england for now
but concern about rising covid numbers
i've always been careful no i'm not
going to do anything different i'm not
from here anyway but
you know i'll just take care it's a
simple equation small percentage of a
large number is still a large number so
that's obvious and we just need to be
careful with that
and with two million booster slots
available the pm is now targeting the
nine million eligible people who still
haven't had their third jab
john craig sky news
well the health minister jillian keegan
joins me now um it's a question we put
to a minister yesterday but does the
government know how many people are
currently self-isolating
well we don't actually collect that data
on a daily basis but it's obvious if you
look at how many people tested positive
yesterday's about 215 000 that they'll
all be self-isolated obviously from the
previous days so it's about a million
people probably are self-isolating right
now
isn't this a figure that you should know
though it seems that you're working on a
load of assumptions and guesses
no you get we get the tested positive
and obviously we get those figures so
you can add those up over the days but
obviously what we don't know is how many
people after day six and day seven have
tested negative and then are free to
leave isolation so it's it's around
about a million people though
okay and
now announced tomorrow by the prime
minister a hundred thousand tests for
critical workers how are they going to
be distributed
uh they will be distributed directly to
the workplaces of those critical workers
so some of it will be via some hubs that
they've set up uh but they are being
distributed so it's a separate channel
separately
directly to those workplaces
it seems quite a low figure a hundred
thousand how did you come up with that
well they've worked with the sector to
look at those are absolutely critical
workers um and what we'll be doing is
delivering a daily test a test every day
so they'll have packs which will
mean that every day that they're they're
they're going to work they'll be able to
take that test but of course we also
have um
mass testing available we're one of the
uh well i think we're testing more per
head than any other country through the
usual channels as well and we actually
had a record for home deliveries
yesterday as well with 741 000 testing
kits that were sent to people's homes
yesterday so you know there are other
channels as well and lots of workers use
those but for nhs social care schools
and also now for this uh critical worker
channels we have separate channels
um
which sectors are actually going to fall
into this category then because we we
spoke to the road haulage association
and they haven't been contacted by the
government they have no idea obviously
lorry drivers are pretty critical aren't
they are they going to be included
it's um fire police emergency services i
think border force testing lab staff
obviously they're quite critical at the
moment
food processing and some elements of
transport but not everybody
in transport would be
considered critical and would need to
have this daily test delivered to them
every day
why not i mean surely lori lori drivers
are pretty critical
well because they can get tests very um
easily actually most people the main
channel for most people is to get tests
via
the the main channels either
booking uh to get something sent to your
home or pharmacies and i know there's
been a couple of surges in demand which
have meant that we have had you know a
couple of times when they haven't been
available but we have ordered a lot of
tests and we have 350 million which will
be available in january and february
we've actually tripled our lateral flow
testing capacity that's one of the
things we've been working on over the
christmas break
there has been a real issue haven't
there i mean i you know anecdotally
there are people who have have tested
positive and are now waiting to go back
to work but they can't because they
can't get
the lateral flow test delivered to their
homes we know as you say these figures
about all these large numbers that are
being produced and shipped out but some
schools are reporting a two-week delay
in receiving kits it's certainly not
going smoothly at the moment is it in
terms of getting it into people's homes
right now
well it's obviously difficult because of
the surge in demand and as i say we're
testing more per head than any other
country in the world but we did have a
record day yesterday uh 741 000 and we
are tripling capacity for january and
february so hopefully that should ease
up some of these sort of short-term uh
difficulties we've had but you know if
you go on and you continue to go on the
website which i know is a bit of a pain
but if you do go back on you will find
that more come available within the day
and as i say a record day yesterday 741
000 kits were delivered to people's
homes
what about the weight for results as
well we know that that has been an issue
the home care association says that some
care workers are waiting over a week for
pcr test results so they can't come back
to work mencap has reported an eight-day
wait for some of its employees
what is the cause of this delay in the
pcr
results it's all surge in demand
actually is what's what's caused some of
this i mean obviously you talked about
some of the numbers with omicron i mean
they're massive number of people coming
forward at once actually to get those so
we have also looked to increase our pcr
capacity as well
but really it has been a surge in demand
we are dealing with unprecedented
numbers and obviously we're getting back
as soon as we possibly can
but as i say we've set up a testing
system which is you know one of one of
the most comprehensive in the world
the pcr you're saying we're setting back
up did it close down over the christmas
new year period
no no no i said we've we've increased
capacity we're increasing capacity in
the labs in the pcr labs it doesn't
close down at all
because the health workers and care
workers are meant to be prioritized
aren't they
yes they are prioritized they have a
separate channel and they are
prioritized both for lateral flow tests
and for pcr tests
why is it taking so long then you know
if the prioritized people are taking
over a week
it doesn't give much hope for the rest
of us
i think that's typical actually i mean
you will find some people are waiting
too long and that's why we've worked on
increasing their capacity but that's not
typical you wouldn't normally expect to
wait a week for a pcr test response and
actually now more and more
the capacity will be being increased and
you know we as i say having more and
more lateral flow tests as well which
people are using before they go out or
before they go to work or before they go
and meet family elderly relatives so
they are
being used very very widely
and despite all of this uh the nhs seems
to be overwhelmed at the moment we've
got a number of trusts with critical
care status the northeast ambulance
service has been reportedly telling some
of its call handlers to tell people
to just bring people in if they think
they're having a heart attack friends or
family instead of calling for an
ambulance the royal college of nursing
has spoke about the fact that this is
not hysteria it's blowing the whistle on
the situation
nhs confederation says that the
government's saying that we're coping
we're managing it doesn't chime with the
experience of the staff um
is the government giving a very
different message than we're hearing
grassroots from those working in the
health service
no i think what it's important for for
you and your viewers to understand is
those
local
measures where somebody
says they're in a critical state they
are actually part of the local
contingency planning and there's a lot
of different levels to the contingency
plan including restricting some services
for a period of time as well which
you've seen one or two of the hospitals
have decided to do and what that acts as
is the start of an escalation process
which then calls in mutual aid calls in
additional staff so they work with the
local resilience forums they work with
their nhs regional staff to then put in
place measures to help with that
situation and that's part of the
contingency planning and actually that
happens every winter these are very
tried and tested plans and it does have
people to take their neighbors to
hospital
they're going to be under extreme
pressure we know that
what about the nhs northeast ambulance
service saying to people look you're not
going to get an ambulance just get your
neighbor to bring you in if you think
you're having a heart attack
well that is that is not uh not what we
what we have put in place at all so we
have more ambulance crews in operation
than we've ever had uh we also gave 55
million pounds extra just for this
period to um
cover staff and make sure that we had
increases in staff and staff in levels
and i've actually asked nhs england to
look at that particular case because
that doesn't sound to me like that is uh
that's that's an acceptable uh approach
people should be able to get an
ambulance if they have a heart attack
and that's why we put that extra funding
in place to make and that's why we've
been building up our ambulance service
over the last couple of years
the prime minister yesterday talked
about riding out this this latest wave
of covert and it's clear from the data
that that omicron isn't as serious in
terms of mortality outcomes that than
other strains like delta were and but
there is of course the impact of long
covert and we're now seeing obviously
it's taken a while for this data to come
forward analysis from america penn
state's researchers found that more than
half of those who had covered 19
still had symptoms six months later so
do you think the government needs to
perhaps take a step back and think again
about its policy in that sense yes
large numbers of the population may not
die
but could large numbers of the
population be affected in the long term
and this could be an issue that we're
storing up for the nhs in months and
years to come
well you hit on a conundrum jane there
which is could it so we have actually
got to act on the data that we have and
that's the decision that we've made this
time the most important thing that we've
done is to build up this booster program
to make sure that everybody can get
access to a booster as soon as possible
so if i could just use the time to urge
everybody who hasn't to please come
forward for one of those two million
appointments this week if you haven't
already had one but of course one
there's been many things we haven't
known we didn't know at the beginning
the severity of the data of the of the
disease and now we've we've had some
good news on that of course we don't
know um
about this particular strain and the
impacts uh longer term we do know a bit
about long coverage which is why we've
set up some long covered clinics and we
are very concerned to make sure that we
uh obviously take care of people who
have long coverage it is debilitating
but you know there's there's so many
unknowns that all we can do is act on
the data that we have because we have to
be balanced and proportionate we know it
is not easy to lock down a country we
know it comes with costs and
consequences to lives to livelihoods to
life chances for children it isn't an
easy decision it's not one to be taken
lightly and that's the balanced and
proportionate approach that we've taken
but it has to we have to act on the data
we have
uh on the data on boosters as you did
did bring them up
why are there are still nine million
people in the uk that haven't had their
boosters and i know that you're
keen to bang on about about all the the
availability of boosters but but only
less than 20 000 people took up that
offer on saturday just gone um yes you
had some days in december with big
numbers but it's fallen off a cliff
since then why have people stopped
getting their booster do you think and
why isn't the government doing more to
get them in
well we are obviously we have a big big
programme of
booster program all across the country
so it's very convenient it's very easy
to get your booster um well i think
there's probably a little bit of a bank
holiday lag obviously we're all just
back now to work and school but there is
also probably another factor that i know
in my own case there's some people who
are still having to wait out their 28
days because they actually have had
kovid as well so i would expect those
people there was a big surge of people
that had covered during december and
over christmas period so they'll have to
wait 28 days so i suspect that's
probably also having an impact on some
people's ability to get the job straight
away but we would urge everybody if
you're eligible if you are within that
28 days if you've had covered please
come forward and please come forward the
quicker we can get everybody
boosted the better we can really be
prepared to what to ride that wave that
the prime minister talked about it's one
of the key parts of our defense our wall
of defense and we're really relying on
this as a national mission for everybody
to come forward please to get their
booster or if they haven't yet been
vaccinated to come forward and get their
job we know they work and they make a
massive difference
jillian keegan minister of state for
care and mental health thank you very
much
thank you
well the latest covert figures saw a
record number of new cases being
reported but behind that figure are a
few quirks in the reporting of the data
especially following christmas and the
holidays
two hundred and eighteen thousand seven
hundred and twenty four new cases of
coronavirus were reported in the latest
24-hour period 48 more people are
reported to have died and that takes the
total of those who've died within 28
days of a positive test to 148
941.
more than 140 000 people got a booster
or a third dose of the coronavirus
vaccine taking the total of those who've
had a third jab to 34.36
million
well europe is also seeing record levels
of covert cases with france becoming the
continent's worst hit country our europe
correspondent michelle clifford joins me
now and michelle france we're not very
keen to let uh britain's come across
christmas time into the country they
were concerned about the spread of
omicron but it seems that they've got an
issue in the country itself
yeah very much so i mean a number of
european union countries reporting
record cases but i think jane that the
uh france is in a particularly
precarious situation a record number of
cases yesterday in excess of 271
000 and this has prompted president
emmanuel macron to take a very hard line
against people who haven't been
vaccinated in fact in an interview with
the french
newspaper using what you call
unpresidential language he says and this
is where i have to be careful he says he
wants to
bleep off
the people who are not
vaccinated um he really wants to take a
hard line against them he insists he
doesn't want to jail people who are
unvaccinated he doesn't want to force
vaccination but what he wants to do is
make it harder for people
to carry out their daily activities
particularly social activities last year
france introduced a health pass where
you either had to prove that you were
vaccinated or produce a negative covid
test to go into places like restaurants
and bars and cinemas there's a bill now
trying to be pushed through parliament
which means that only unvaccinated
people can go into those places
a negative test
will not be permitted and this has
created not only a great amount of
dissension and anger from certainly
those opposed to that move but it's
become very sinister a number of
parliamentarians saying they've received
death threats over this proposed
legislation but france is not alone a
number of as i say eu countries have
reported record rates of covered spain
uh has now said that over a 14-day
infection rate period it's seeing record
results um and omicron is approaching
almost half of those who are infected
but spain insisting that children will
be able to go back to school students to
university
uh in the netherlands where there's been
a lockdown
they're saying there has been a 35
increase over the last week in terms of
covey cases so this is problem that's
not isolated uh to the uk it's a problem
that the whole of the european union now
is embracing
michelle thanks a lot
still to come on the show the government
is to review covert travel restrictions
today but what can we expect to change
we're going to talk to a travel expert
at a quarter to weight
labour says boris johnson needs a plan
to deal with pressures on the country's
services we'll talk to the shadow chief
secretary to the treasury pat mcfadden
and the cost of living crisis for some
of society's most vulnerable we'll talk
to age uk as it warns rising fuel and
gas prices could seriously threaten the
health of older people this winter
that's at half past eight
a u.s judge will decide soon whether a
civil sexual assault case against prince
andrew will be dismissed following the
latest hearing in new york the duke of
york and his lawyers have argued he's
covered by a 2009 deal at his accuser
virginia dufrey made with the late
paedophile geoffrey epstein ms dufrey
has accused prince andrew of sexually
assaulting her when she was 17 a claim
that he has denied skies joe pike
reports
did he sexually assault a 17 year old
girl or is he the victim of false
accusations and innuendo prince andrew
doesn't just deny having sex with
virginia dufrese but even remembering
meeting her i have no recollection of
ever meeting this lady
none whatsoever
after years of difficult headlines and
just days after the duke's close friend
gelaine maxwell was convicted of child
sex trafficking
this hearing was his best chance to end
the case
prince andrew's team argue a 2009
settlement between miss dufrey and the
pedophile jeffrey epstein protects other
potential defendants like him from being
sued
but the document also says the terms of
this settlement agreement are not
intended to be used by any other person
andrew bretler acting for the prince
also argued in court that mr frey needs
to lock herself into a story now she
needs to allege when he supposedly
abused her we don't even have a date a
time a location
the judge louis kaplan responded with
all due respect mr bretler that is not a
dog that is going to hunt here i
understand your point it just isn't the
law
if prince andrew is successful at
getting this case dismissed he will have
done so not by proving his innocence but
on a legal technicality by claiming
virginia dufrese can't sue him because
she's already settled with his
paedophile friend and the judge in this
case lewis kaplan seemed pretty
skeptical of the arguments made by the
duke of york's lawyers suggesting he may
decide to let this case continue
some legal experts believe that carrying
on with the case could be best for
prince andrew's reputation
if the prince uh is looking to
you know survive this from a public
persona perspective and a public
relations perspective he's going to have
to get down to the facts and if he can
defend this case on the merits and win
on the merits then he may be able to
reestablish his public personality but
if he just gets off on this based on a
technicality i think it's going to be
disastrous for his reputation and his
first for his future if the case does
continue virginia duprey's lawyers will
want to question the duke of york under
oath before the trial which is due to
begin this autumn joe pike sky news new
york
also making the news this morning north
korea has fired a suspected ballistic
missile off its east coast according to
authorities in the region the reports
follow leader kim jong-un's new year vow
to bolster the military to counter
what's been called an unstable
international situation japan's coast
guard which first reported the launch
said it could be a ballistic missile but
didn't provide further details
former soldier from colombia has been
charged in the u.s in connection with
the killing of the haitian president
javanelle moyes last july mario antonio
palacios is charged with conspiracy to
commit murder or kidnapping outside the
u.s and providing material support
resulting in death he appeared in
federal court in miami after being found
hiding in jamaica
well let's return to covert now and the
surge in infections across the country
placing the nhs under continued pressure
with multiple trusts declaring critical
incidents and hospitals in greater
manchester pausing non-urgent surgery
well joining me now is professor paul
moss from the institute of immunology
and in authority immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham he also sits on
stage uh good to talk to you today um
professor moss um so no move from plan b
as we heard yesterday from the prime
minister there are concerns by quite a
few different parts of the medical
profession
that they would like greater
restrictions
is holding steady now the right thing to
do do you think
i think we heard a balanced argument
didn't we from the prime minister chris
whitley patrick valance yesterday and as
i said it's a moment of utmost caution
but i think it's something that we can
follow at the moment but with regular
review we heard there's great pressures
in hospitals at the moment rising
admissions as you said and also staff
absences are a huge problem
but as we said yesterday the couple of
things that we're dealing with at the
moment that give us some hope are that
the
omicron virus variant is certainly
clinically less severe that's now become
quite apparent and also the booster
vaccination campaign is going very
strongly and we're hoping that those two
factors will get us through
would greater restrictions change the
pressure on the nhs do you think or or
is omicron now so widespread in the
country that actually possibly wouldn't
make very much difference
i think you make a very interesting
point and you just heard your reporter
around europe where there's a range of
different restrictions and
they're seeing very high waves of
omicron infection of course very severe
restrictions can make a difference but
of course they come at a cost as well to
lives and livelihoods so i think we know
what our situation is in the england and
uk and scotland and so forth and i think
for the moment we'll have to see how
this plays out day by day or week by
week
as you said we heard yesterday
definitive news that the nomicron is is
a milder variant in some respects which
is great news uh but there was also the
numbers people who have it one in 25 now
have it um according to the data we
showed yesterday it was one in 270 a
while ago
it seems like a massive jump but is that
natural in a virus like this
i think it's now it's probably november
the 7th it's about two months since
we've known omicron and what do we know
so far we know a couple of very
interesting things one is it's
incredibly infectious because it sticks
to the cells of our nose and mouth very
very efficiently and that's why as you
said last week one in 25 people in the
uk had on micron we're seeing it around
the world so incredibly infectious but
at the same time the virus has also
changed it seems as if it replicates
much better in the cells of our upper
airways but less so in the lungs which
is very important because we know that
lung infection and pneumonia was such a
severe complication so we're starting to
get some handle on the biology of why it
might be well it appears to be a less
severe infection which is quite
interesting and hopeful of course this
is not a common cold this is still a
severe disease but certainly less so
than the previous variants
and what did you make of the information
they gave us about london where it seems
that the
the growth of omacron there is slowing
although it is still growing um but but
i thought what's quite interesting is
the fact that it's it's slowing faster
amongst the young amongst the group that
aren't necessarily the most vaccinated
what do you make of that
yes we've certainly seen omicron in many
countries actually in fact in the
younger population more so children as
well of course children less vaccinated
as well so yes there is data already and
and the zoe app um suggesting that in
younger people in london that the cases
may well have already plateaued and
perhaps be declining
things can't go on doubling every two or
three days forever so there is some hope
there but around the rest of the country
of course the cases are still increasing
quite markedly
how tough do you know do you think the
next two or three weeks might be
they're going to be very tough i think
the prime minister said yesterday a
moment for most caution i think in
hospitals uh incredible pressure with
hospitalizations
and also staff
absences it's gonna be a very difficult
few weeks
okay um paul moss from the institute of
immunology and immunotherapy at the
university of birmingham thank you mark
very much for joining us thank you thank
you
let's get a look at the weather now
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well today will be cold and largely fine
apart from a few wintry showers but
thursday will bring rain sleet and hill
snow
it's a mostly dry start with an
extensive frost but wintry showers are
affecting the north and the west and
they'll bring icy stretches especially
for northern scotland and northern
ireland plenty of morning sunshine but
parts of the north and west will see
further wintry showers mostly affecting
northern scotland northern ireland and
wales
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now on monday a winter storm in the u.s
unleashed snow and strong winds
throughout much of the southeast and
mid-atlantic and we've got new pictures
from washington d.c where a crowd of
people gathered near the capital to
launch snowballs at each other uh in a
nod to the coronavirus omicron variant
the event was dubbed
the battle of snomocron by a facebook
group that organizes regular snowball
fights
oh to live in a country where you could
have a face group group that does such a
thing
it all looks very good natured and quite
amount of social distancing going on
there as well which is good to see
still to come on sky news breakfast
prince andrew awaits a ruling from a u.s
judge to determine whether the sexual
assault lawsuit against him will be
thrown out we'll have the very latest
[Music]
now as mps returned to westminster today
the prime minister boris johnson will
tell his cabinet that there's no need
for more covert restrictions despite
omacron cases reaching record levels the
health minister jillian keegan told us
earlier at least a million people are
currently self-isolating
if you look at how many people tested
positive yesterday is about 215 000 that
they'll all be self-isolated obviously
from the previous days so it's about a
million people probably are
self-isolating right now what we don't
know is how many people after day six
and day seven have tested negative and
then are free to leave isolation so it's
it's around about a million people
though
well tomorrow was listening to that our
political correspondence so a certain
amount of guesswork from the government
still but they seem to have a clear idea
roughly of how many people are that's
right first confirmation from the
government that it is a million at least
a million because of course we don't
know for how many people that red line
goes away after seven days or whether it
continues so that could be more and of
course unvaccinated people are still
supposed to quarantine if they're in
contact with someone with covid or
people who are effectively
self-isolating because say the two
parents have coveted and the children
don't but they can't then go out
anywhere so it could be a lot more than
that but she gave a sense of how serious
this is with how many people are stuck
at home and this comes with the news
that i've um heard this morning that the
government are now planning to change
the rules on testing so currently if you
get a positive lateral flow you've got
to get a pcr test at a testing center to
confirm it i expect at some point in the
next couple of days the government is
going to announce that you no longer
have to do that if you get your positive
lateral flow test they are accurate
enough that you can then just do your
seven days at home straight away because
of course the testing capacity is really
stretched at the moment they're doing
one and a half million tests a day
officials tell me that's the highest in
europe one of the highest in the world
so they need to reduce the pressure but
of course how will we then know how many
people have covered it will rely uh
jillian keegan just told me on people
doing the right thing and registering
that lateral flow test result every time
they do one so it could really mess with
the data that we're getting so it does
rely on people doing the right thing i
suppose and a lot of people you know and
i confess i may have even done this
ourselves in our family will have done a
test but forgotten to register it
absolutely if you're doing them all the
time you might think right haven't got
covered and and throw it away but you
are supposed to register every test
result because otherwise um of course
the important business of knowing how
much the infection is spreading and
where and where the hot spots are is
done through those pcr test results so
there's a lot to be thought through on
this change but um the government know
they need to prioritize that capacity
that's why they've come up with this
hundred thousand really really critical
workers in nuclear power and transport
of food and so on who will get tests
every day they don't want the general
population to be clogging up these uh
pcr testing centers okay tomorrow thanks
very much
now a new york judge says he will decide
pretty soon whether to continue a civil
suit made against prince andrew virginia
dufrey claims that the duke of york
sexually assaulted her as a teenager
which he denies i'm joined now by nigel
cawthorn author of prince andrew epstein
and the palace good to talk to you today
how damaging do you think what came out
in court was yesterday for the prince
oh i'm sorry we can't hear you
apologies about that we'll try and
return to that interview a few technical
problems here in the meantime the
president of kazakhstan has accepted the
resignation of the country's government
after an increase in liquid gas prices
triggered violent protests in the
country which began on sunday let's talk
to our correspondent diana magnay who
joins us now and diana say who's in
charge
well the government has resigned um but
i think that's generally a scapegoat
especially in the sort of ex-soviet
space the government takes the hit
for
uh unrest on the streets but still
you you put your finger on it really
who's in charge it's not actually the
president takayev um it's still uh north
sultan nusobayaf who stood down as
president two years ago um but who
effectively still runs the country and
he has been the effective leader of
kazakhstan since soviet times and i
think what we saw in the last three days
as these protests spread from the
western oil producing regions all the
way through the major cities of
kazakhstan was an expression of
anger really that nothing has changed in
the way that kazakhstan has run and that
nazarbayev is still in charge he's not
president but he runs the security
council his family is still very much in
control of a lot of the infrastructure
of the country and it was a sort of
rollout of social and economic
grievances and frustrations which was
triggered by a a a a lifting of price
caps on a liq unliquified natural gas
which a lot of people especially in that
oil producing region use to fill up
their cars because it's a lot cheaper
than petrol um but i think that the
protests that we saw then spreading
across the country were really in
solidarity with those early protests and
a much stronger
feeling of grievance so the government
has resigned let's just have a listen to
what president takayev had to say
those calls to attack the government and
military buildings are completely
illegal
this is a crime that could be followed
by punishment
the government will not fall but we want
mutual trust and dialogue rather than
conflict
well the government did fall
and takayev has promised also to
keep a cap on uh fuel prices on food
prices on electricity prices for six
months to at least try and appease
protesters but we are still seeing
protests in a couple of cities there has
been a state of emergency declared in
the western part of the country and in
the capital al marti that will probably
mean that those protests eventually die
down
but i think what you heard there is the
fact that there will be repercussions
for protesters and uh the protests now
are largely calling for any sort of
prosecution for those people who came
out onto the streets to be dropped i
think it's typical of
protest movements in essentially
autocratic states that people who go out
onto the streets know that fundamentally
the security forces will come after them
and that is why these regimes are able
to keep themselves keep themselves going
effectively
diana good to talk to you thanks very
much
let's return to the story about prince
andrew and the court case that's going
on in america uh let's try and now
rejoin nigel corton author of prince
andrew epstein and the palace and we
think we've sorted out the technical
problems nigel um so i was asking you
how damaging was what happened in court
in america yesterday
well uh judge kaplan didn't seem at all
sympathetic to the arguments put forward
by prince andrews attorneys um
and
he wants to give a written ruling so
that it may take a few days before we
hear this but it seems to me that even
if he did throw this case out
at this point uh it would it would do
andrew no good at all because he would
be seen to be dodging the bullet but by
the use of some sleazy agreement signed
by a convicted pedophile
in indeed and and almost is there any
implication of guilt
from that because
you know if if it says you can't sue
anybody um you know who's accused does
that even in it in itself uh
lend more credence to the allegations
against him
well indeed because at no point uh has
he subjected to himself to do interviews
by the fbi who who requested them
several times in this matter um nor has
he uh answered any of the substances of
the allegations made against him
and you just shown that that famous
picture
again um which since the uh conviction
of uh
galen maxwell is is even more damning
because there she is a convicted sex
trafficker in the back
um
smiling and uh 17 year old virginia
gouffrey who claims that she was
trafficked and prince andrew who says he
wasn't there
if prince andrew was able to stop this
particular case are there any other
legal avenues open for mr frey
well it is again it seems to me that
that the allegations that she's made
both
to the authorities in america and to
scotland yard here include rape in the
first degree which is is a pretty
serious uh offense and um
i i i don't see why that that some
criminal investigation isn't going on
um we spoke to legal expert joshua
rosenberg yesterday and he said his
instinct is that this
will not reach a trial that this will be
settled out of court in some kind of
financial settlement is is that your
instinct too from watching it closely
well again it would be very embarrassing
if it went to court but then again if
there is some sort of uh
legal settlement that that's down to
amount to an admission of some sort of
guilt and and secondly i'm sure the
british tax paper players will be asking
well who's actually paying that the
damages to virginia goofy
do you think prince andrew can ever have
a a public role within the royal family
again after all of this whether or not
it it comes to a case
i see him see i think it is very
difficult to to see this unless he he
goes through uh with the whole process
uh appears in in court uh answers the
questions uh put to him uh by uh
virginia guthrie's attorneys and and uh
quits himself well
i mean he has of course always denied
any involvement in any of this and
denied all the charges against him uh
but here we are still you know years
after that the charges were first
suggested um still talking about it how
do you feel this has all been handled by
his legal team and his pr team
well very badly indeed we must as you
say give
prince sandra the presumption of
innocence but uh if he was
if uh
the palace like to call themselves the
firm
if this was any other company uh in the
world uh he would have been sacked by
now
nigel cawthorne good to talk to you
thanks a lot for joining us
thank you
well there's been fury in australia
after it was announced now that djokovic
was given a medical exemption from
needing a kovid jab to be able to
complete in the australian open here's
what the british doubles player jamie
murray had to say
i don't know what to say about that
really
i mean
you know i think if it was
me that wasn't vaccinated i wouldn't be
getting an exemption
um and that's
you know but
well done you know well done to him for
getting cleared to
come to australia and
and compete
well sky news australia's samantha kiari
has the latest from perth
overwhelmingly since this news broke
late last night there has been uproar in
regards to this decision now there's
been a bit of confusion surrounding how
novak djokovic got approved to enter the
country particularly given the strict
stance uh the victorian premier daniel
andrews has on being vaccinated in order
to enter the state and he was approved
by otagi so he wasn't approved by the
victorian government or tennis australia
it was all done through otagi which of
course is the medical body which gives
exemptions for people to enter the
country if they're not vaccinated since
this news broke there has been no
support whatsoever for novak djokovic
from media commentators to just your
average australian on the street
everyone is up in arms over this
decision particularly given the strict
arduous conditions many melbournians
face now the australian open takes place
in the capital city of victoria which is
melbourne they've had two years of
lockdown the most locked down city in
the world and they have very strict
conditions in regards to being
vaccinated in order to just enter the
pub so in saying that you'd be close to
saying there hasn't been any any support
uh if any for the world number one novak
djokovic it's certainly going to be an
interesting tournament taking place from
january 17.
and we shall be watching it still come
on sky news breakfast
with a government review of omicron
rules expected today what could changes
in the world of travel we're going to
talk to a travel expert in a moment
[Music]
the government will review covert travel
measures in england today it comes with
a travel sector calling for the
pre-departure and day two tests to be
dropped to try to revive consumer
confidence well joining me now is the
founder and chief executive of the
travel consultancy the pc agency paul
charles and paul
is this the main thing that you're
hoping for the dropping of these two
levels of testing
yes there's absolutely no reason now why
these tests are needed you could
understand why they were needed at the
start of this omicron variant saga but
actually now when omicron is so virulent
across the uk
it doesn't make any sense for tests to
be in place for pre-departure into the
uk when the government doesn't even get
that data it doesn't control or own that
data in any way so the pre-departure
test should go
they're hurting the travel recovery and
they're hurting travel firms large and
small across the sector
and in addition those data arrival tests
should be dropped there's no reason why
i should have to take one on arrival in
the uk when i could take a train across
the uk and not have to take any tests at
all there's no difference to getting on
a train from london to edinburgh as
there is from brussels to london
but do you think that there is any
evidence that it is really putting
people off traveling i mean everybody
knows now that if you are going to
travel there are a certain number of
tests that have to be carried out and
it's just part now part and parcel
unfortunately of where we are
well i think we should be at the very
least going back to where we were with
the delta variant which is simple
lateral flow testing on arrival in the
uk if you have to do any tests at all
but undoubtedly the measures that have
been put in place of damaging consumer
confidence they reduce bookings people
say i can't be bothered with the faf and
the hassle of doing it and that's
indicated by the numbers seen from
travel companies the slump in demand
that they've seen over the christmas and
new year period and they do need vital
bookings at this time because this is a
harsh period anyway in a normal year
winter is not that busy so firms have to
take all the cash they can in this
period and if consumer confidence is
damaged during this period some smaller
firms find it hard to get through to the
summer
and in terms of the prices of the of the
travel testing there were some real
rip-off prices weren't there especially
over the summer have they largely gone
or is it still really expensive
it's still expensive and the travel
testing sector is still highly
unregulated the government have not
clamped down in the way they promised on
the prices especially a pcr test there
are still too many firms operating what
the government's called cowboy tactics
in the past they're still operating
those they're still not supplying the
service they promise at the price they
promise so the whole testing arena has
been a sorry saga and it's time now for
the government to remove many of those
tests they're simply not appropriate
do you accept though that there are
countries with with low levels of covet
and that that there should be testing
before anybody travels to those
countries
well of course the omicron variant was
discovered by scientists doing their job
very well on the ground in south africa
it wasn't discovered from a traveler's
test that happened once somebody was
back in the uk
so as long as scientists are doing their
fantastic work on the ground finding out
if variants are emerging then there's no
reason for these tests to be in place in
fact if you're traveling on a plane or a
train internationally or a ferry
let's help the sector recover the
government of promised and the prime
minister has promised to protect jobs to
help improve the sector and he can do
that very easily by removing these tests
and letting the scientists do their work
every day on the ground
paul charles we're going to leave it
there thanks very much
coming up after the break on sky news
the government tells us at least a
million people are isolating as
essential services face disruption stay
with us
[Music]